in the streets of yangon
peaceful protesters remain determined
even in the face of force
many of them wore hard hats and tried to
protect themselves with makeshift
barricades
occupying the streets to fight against
military rule
this footage shows police firing at
unarmed demonstrators
in the country's northwest several
people were injured when police used
water cannon and tear gas
as the attacks on peaceful
demonstrations continue
myanmar's neighbours in southeast asia
held their first meeting
since the military coup the talks were
held virtually and behind closed doors
indonesia is the largest democracy in
southeast asia
and has been at the forefront of the
push for asean to help resolve the
crisis in myanmar
indonesia's foreign minister
acknowledges that while non-interference
is enshrined in the asean charter so too
is a commitment to peace stability
and good governance
the indonesian foreign minister said her
country is very concerned about the
violence in myanmar
[Music]
it's worrisome because an increasing
number of civilians have lost their
lives or
are injured singapore's prime minister
joined those calling for the release of
myanmar's democratically elected leaders
to arrest dao aun sangsuki as well as
her ministers and the president
and charge them with
walkie-talkie offenses and things like
that i don't think that's going to help
solve the problem
malaysia's foreign ministry said the
resolution to what it called a political
deadlock
must be a domestic-led process
experts say asean must come up with a
plan rather than reflecting on whether
it should or should not be part of the
solution
asean vision or asean plan or asean
expectation must in the center of it all
i believe place the democratic wish
and will of the people of myanmar must
be at the fall
while asean member states try to decide
what they can do to resolve this crisis
a battle with higher stakes is playing
out on the streets
jessica washington al jazeera jakarta